well the government's big pro-eu leaflet
is out with lots of facts and figures
about the benefits of membership of the
European Union but do they all stack up
according to the Sky News specialist
first of all let's take economics and
there's a big claim about forty four
percent of UK exports going across into
the EU now there is true but it's worth
noting it's in decline a few years ago
the number was about fifty percent
secondly there's the claim amount being
inside the common market and how that
makes life cheaper for businesses now of
course that's true as well but even if
the UK were outside the EU and have an
arrangement a bit like Norway we'd still
be inside the common market finally
there's a big fact 540 billion pounds
worth of foreign direct investment going
into the UK over the course of the past
decade the big question though is
whether that investment would have
happened anyway even if we were outside
Europe economic issues are relevant many
of the key social questions too by far
the most incendiary of which is
immigration the leaflet says that if we
left the EU much like Norway which isn't
a member but still needs access to that
crucial EU single market we would still
have to accept EU immigration others say
we could cut it down by a hundred
thousand a year if we left the EU the
truth is we don't know but it would
depend on exactly what we could
negotiate in order to secure access to
that crucial market and remember
immigrations the two-way street the
leaflet warns that travel perks we
currently enjoy the ability to travel
and work widely in Europe at a cheap
cost would become harder and more
expensive in the event of a brexit and
there's no question that in the short
term at least that claim is true and
what about things that aren't mentioned
in the leaflet at all employment rights
like working hours and parental leave
protection from discrimination and
equality those are things that are
currently guaranteed by Brussels and if
we left the EU we'd be at the mercy of
whichever British government was in
place it's very hard to measure security
when we're trying to assess whether or
not Britain would be safer inside the EU
or outside the EU one thing that will
never ever change and that is that
Britain is an island which does make
borders easy to protect much easier than
on
continental Europe by being a member of
the EU Britain is also a part of Europol
which gives police forces here access to
data and fingerprint records from other
police forces around Europe and that
would cease to be the case if Britain
were to leave the European Union the
leaflet also correctly points out that
around a thousand criminals have been
arrested on the continent and brought
back to the UK to face justice using
what's known as the European Arrest
Warrant however only one terrorist has
been detained using those powers
ultimately no one yet has made the case
decisively that proves that Britain
would be safer if it were to leave the
EU and as ed and a foie have pointed out
this leaflet for its facts all its
figures doesn't decide the case one way
or the other